is that with the leaving ladies I don't
really hits a nerd with you guys ladies
you want a guy to stay make him want to
stay like guys we have pickup lines
ladies you need to stay put lines that's
where you kick in it's okay I approached
you at a bar I was nervous I was on my
heels shucking and jiving I made it work
now you want me to hang out so you do it
isn't that Justice she's like well
you're not being that fun right now I'm
like I already did that that's how I
[ __ ] you
but now you you will stay so you go it's
just a shift
the Chevy over Char me sweep me off my
feet you do it
I don't get it girls always like I want
this guy to like me you push your boobs
together wear high heels you look sexy
as hell then a guy is sex you're like
that's it well that's what was
advertised
it's very confusing you tricked me your
outfit's like a movie trailer I'm like
oh I want to see that movie I go see the
movie then I go home I don't sit around
going I gotta get to know this theater
and I'm not saying the theater sucks or
anything's wrong with it just wasn't
advertised talk to me I'd love to get I
had a girl once you can't leave you
[ __ ] me
well is this is this how you get people
to hang out with you